bienvenue un stephen lang je pars à 18h
paravent ont fait ensemble collaboratif
hockey quand on en a marre battu parce
que ça y est sinon je te fais ci bonjour
n'a battu passe-passe like tout de suite
non bah voilà ça commence en arrière
tout de suite voilà
bonjour le chien je vais vous présenter
un projet qu'on est en train de mettre
qu'on est en train de construire
c'est un projet qui se veut citoyen et
que je construis en collaboration avec
claude aubry
là tu peux y aller je travaille dans une
coopérative un truc du genre
ces deux là ils sont un peu la
naphtaline le
en fait on a choisi coopérative ans on
sait monter on a construit cette
coopérative à quatre et on a choisi le
statut de scop parce que parce qu'il y
avait des sept statues qui se
rapprochait le plus de ce qu'on avait
envie de faire de nos valeurs et en fait
dans dans la scop en fait le but de la
scop si j'ai bien compris c'est de créer
son son outil de travail de le
pérenniser
et puis un truc que j'avais pas de
transmettre après en fait ça
ressemblerait plus à ça ce qu'on est en
train de monter ou moi j'aimerais bien
que ça ressemble un petit peu à ça un
truc dans les scop en fait c'est
coopératif coopératif mois dans quand
j'entends ce mot je pense ça on poursuit
le même but le même objectif un petit
peu comme conçu comme quand on construit
une maison mais ça veut pas dire qu'en
fait le l'électricien il va rencontrer
le plombier c'est pas sûr du tout moi je
le vois comme une collaboratif plutôt un
truc collaboratif l'image qui me parlent
le plus c'est le truc qui vient après ce
serait la danse là on voit bien dans
cette image qu'en fait on devine bien
que les deux personnes qui sont là qui
sont des hommes parce que parce que
souvent les développeurs sont des hommes
et on en reparlera peut-être après en
fait on en reparlera pas mais là on voit
bien qu'il ya énormément de travail
individuel en fait il en vache mambo
c'est tout seul donc être collaboratif
c'est très fatiguant on va pas le faire
on va on va pas le faire souvent le fait
de temps en temps c'est pour ça qu'il ya
des pépites collaborative
dans la scop où je bosse en fait on
essaye de travailler pour l'économie
sociale et solidaire c'est ça qui nous
intéresserait mes collaborateurs il y
arrive mais coopérateurs il y arrive les
trois ont bossé pour firefox pour faire
des applications web pour firefox
moi je bosse plus tôt pour ce qui vient
derrière c'est à dire pour l'économie
cynique et suicidaire que j'essaye de
quitter doucement tous ces projets là
sont vaguement utile des fois ils se
plantent forte heureusement en fait le
et derrière en fait on essaye aussi de
bosser pour ça pour l'open source
ça c'est un voeu pieux en fait on
aimerait bien bossé pour pour ça et
quand on essaye de bosser sur sûr ça en
fait quand on y arrive du moins on fait
des trucs qui sont qui sont pour nous
pour nous et a surtout pas fait pas sa
malheureuse le en fait on bosse pour
nous c'est bien comme ça on bosse pour
nous c'est à dire qu'en fait on fait des
on fait des projets à destination des
des vins et d'avé citoyen on est dans un
truc un peu bizarre serre que les
citoyens nous prennent un peu pour des
techniciens pour des geeks ce qui est
pas du tout le cas et pour nous en fait
de fond de notre piscine numérique
là tu peux admettre qu'on voit un peu
les citoyens comme ça quand ils
débarquent avec leur cahier des charges
en un seul mot tu vois qui viennent avec
leurs expressions fonctionnel il nous
faudrait un site web qu'ils fassent ça
et ça et ça c'est combien
[ __ ] c'est combien je sais même pas ce
que tu veux et toi non plus
ok donc en fait on a monté on essaye de
monter ce truc là qui vient après c'est
vraiment une presse de psychopathe c'est
pour ça je suis un peu tendu lorsqu'il
ya vachement de slide à faire défiler il
ya des gens bien dans la salle un fou on
essaye de monter de gymkhana gymkhana
c'est un atelier de co construction
citoyenne
en fait on le veut comme ça les
gymkhanas avant c'était well as tu peux
y aller c'était des trucs un peu comme
ça en fait c'étaient des c'est vieux
c'est début 20e but 21e fin xxème quoi
et en fait c'est des endroits où on fait
des jeux ou des activités sportives ça
ressemble un peu à des kermesses 1
ça c'est ce qu'on veut faire dans les
ateliers de co construction citoyenne
on aimerait faire en fait des
applications web ça pourrait ressembler
à une problématique comme celle ci qui
est le micro covoiturage micro
covoiturage en fait vincent on en avait
parlé c'est un collaborateur
il m'en avait parlé et quand j'ai été à
bordeaux pour un truc qui s'appelait
métro num
en fait le président de l'as de la
communauté urbaine d'agglomération un
truc de ce genre il parlait en fait de
ses problèmes de rocade de l'engorgement
qu'il y avait dans les rocades avec sa
rocade et il disait il faudrait il
faudrait que je rage a grandi star aux
quatre ça va coûter un camion d'euros et
en plus les bordelais qu'est ce qu'ils
vont faire ils ont leur voiture garée au
garage parce que sinon bouteille est
tout le temps là ils vont la sortir
quand il va y avoir la rocade et du coup
le problème va revenir et en fait il a
fait une petite étude en parallèle et il
s'est aperçu que on rajouterait une
personne par voiture 25% des problèmes
en fait ce serait résolu à lancer des
chiffres on n'est pas sûr du du truc
mais du coup on sent bien que là on
pourrait faire peut-être une application
et que ce serait que ça pourrait être
pas mal si on fait une application fait
quoi on coopère ou ans collabore moi ça
c'est un truc
en fait on l'a fait on l'a fait quelle
manière est ce qu'on est ce qu on part
d'une idée ouah c'est supermicro
covoiturage maintenant je vais de cette
idée là je vais construire en fait je
vais faire le cahier des charges dans le
truc je vais faire ma vision hayat dans
très longtemps je sais exactement ce que
je veux faire on y va on le fait
et puis puis je vais pas me tromper puis
des citoyens c'est ce qu'ils vont
utiliser c'est très bien ou alors
l'autre vision ces jeux bas j'ai une
idée super maintenant on va faire des
petites hypothèse à chaque fois qu'on va
voir une hypothèse on va là on va la
tester on va vérifier c'est ça surtout
si on a des certitudes on va avoir des
certitudes tous les voyants rouges à
l'intérieur on transforme ça en
hypothèse on teste ça et puis si ça
marche on augmente et on augmente petit
à petit pour choisir entre les deux j'ai
mis le voyant je vais en reparler après
avec sa boule de cristal pour choisir
entre les deux buzzword ici innovant
tout le monde en parle
innovant qui sait ce que c'est dans la
salle
quelques-uns ne vais pas les bras c'est
pas la peine je vois rien c'est dans le
noir ouais philippe médaille c'est ça
quand il regarde pas son portable
pendant que je fais ma confiance était
fanny aussi enfin bon il ya des gens qui
il ya des gens qui connaissent moi je
connais pas trop mais je sais que je
sais qu'il faut choisir et quand on
choisit en fait s'il modèle si on
connaît le modèle si on est en train de
refaire un truc qui existe qui existait
déjà à ce moment là à ce moment là c'est
pas innovant et puis on peut prendre
l'autre truc mais si on fait quelque
chose de nouveau
doigts fins de nouveaux pas de 9 ans
d'innovant à ce moment là tout va
émerger le modèle économique va émerger
le design peut émerger larchitecture va
émerger les fonctionnalités vont émerger
et là c'est pas pareil
du coup une petite approche potagères
serait serait peut-être la bienvenue
c'est hier que au lieu de construire un
gros truc bien énorme avec une avec une
vision avec une vision très solution en
fait on va construire juste un petit
potager un petit truc avec un plant de
tomate un truc un truc très facile très
très facile à construire et de la dola
on va vérifier qu'en fait les citoyens
veulent ce truc là
et puis on et puis on va continuer on va
tirer dessus
du coup on va améliorer on va mettre un
plan de basilic on va vérifier encore
plan de basilic machin ouais ça aussi et
puis les citoyens vont nous demander un
plan de mozzarella et
on va avoir un peu de problèmes non mais
à la fin à la fin peut-être qu'on va
atterrir sur le produit qui va être la
trottinette qui va solutionner en fait
notre problème de covoiturage si ce
n'était pas une application web ça
pourrait être ce truc là en fait la
solution engorgement de bordeaux quand
même sauvé bordeaux avec ce truc là je
te laisse passer ouais en fait la proche
et pas du tout la même que d'habitude
afin que l'autre approche dans l'autre
approche en fait on fait un truc genre
la trottinette là on l'a fait d'entrée
et on dit c'est ça que les citoyens ils
veulent ils vont se l'arracher ma
solution c'est sûr ccc ce qu'ils veulent
dans l'autre dans l'autre solution c'est
les citoyens qui tire en fait
en fait ils disent ouais c'est bien ce
que tu as fait l'achat l'utiliser
maintenant ce serait vachement mieux si
tu rajoutes est requins et puis et puis
en fait on arrive sur deux paradigmes
alors surtout tu passes pas l'autre tout
de suite
celui-ci en fait c'est un des paradigmes
c'est celui que vous connaissez le mieux
je pense c'est celui que moi je
connaissais mieux en tous les cas c'est
sauter en ciseau c'est tout ce temps six
autres est très haut et en fait quand on
saute en ciseau ce serait si on
reprenait ce paradigme la fin si ce
serait le paradis de la business plan un
petit peu fier que j'arrive il ya
beaucoup de voyance en fait comme on a
vu tout à l'heure et puis un peu
d'hypnose cercueil j'ai une solution
enfin j'ai une idée d'abord j'ai une
petite idée et là tout de suite on va on
va m'encourager tout le monde les
incubateurs aussi tout le monde va dire
ouais vase il va chercher la solution
est la solution là je lai a perdu
surtout ta solution à trois ans à trois
ans comment tu seras comment comment
elle sera ta solution à trois ans à cinq
ans à 5 ans c'est encore mieux si tu le
fais à cinq ans on y croit encore plus
hélas une fois qu'une fois que j'ai été
voir le voyant qu'ils m'avaient d'iwata
solution à 5 ans elle est la regarde de
business plans d'entre eux je vais voir
les investisseurs et la séance d'hypnose
fait confiance croit en moi et là tu
lèves l'autre solution en fait c'est
vraiment un changement de paradigme
tu peux y aller c'est faux ce bruit
c'est un autre truc dire que j'illustre
ça parce que ces ruptures quoi c'est
vraiment il ya un truc rupture innovant
machin bingo bullshit
le truc qui sautant is hot fuzz brisseau
juste autrement ils sont peut-être pas
beaucoup plus haut peut-être j'aurais pu
inverser ils sont différemment c'est
tout c'est un autre truc c'est un autre
paradigme
si tu fais ça en fait c'est pas pareil
tu vas faire ça tu as une solution
vachement 21 une idée vachement bien on
peut tous en avoir la à la minute quoi
après c'est la mise en oeuvre comment on
fait on va faire un petit truc moi je
suis sûr que tu voudrais ça ok je te le
fais c'est ça que tu voulais d'ailleurs
je suis sûr d'abord c'est je suis sûr
que tu es problème c'est ça c'est ça tu
es problèmes non c'est pas ça bon ok
d'accord
et puis je vais à chaque fois j'ai des
certitudes va les tester comme ça et
puis je vais construire doucement mon
projet tu peux y aller ah bah voilà ça
c'est un citoyen en fait il a essayé de
faire un saut en ciseaux en face burris
et il a essayé de faire un truc et la
chute qui est là elle a rien à voir avec
les chutes qu'on va voir tout à l'heure
cette chute l'a en fait elle est
franchement douloureuse c1 il va pas
semble enfin mal 100 m à chaque fois
vous superposées comme ça les deux
paradigmes ce que font à peu près tous
les gens c'est un mémoire du mister vous
voulez faire de la gym
ah ouais ouais super là ce que tu m'as
dit c'est génial on y va ouais mais là
maintenant stop on débraye on va faire
comme d'habitude
et pareil sur l'autre là où elle voulait
donc on fait pas du prédictif en fait
l'adaptative on va s'adapter aux
changements
ouais mais là quand même il faudrait
prévoir un peu des trucs donc le truc ça
va être vraiment devriez passer de
l'autre côté je sais pas il faut voir la
lumière et pour voir la lumière moi j'ai
un truc vachement bien tu peux y aller
c'est en fait les jeux on utilise ça
depuis tu vois depuis longtemps fait des
jeux comme ça c'est on sait tous faire
des jeux soit on pourrait faire une conf
là dessus c'est vachement plus
intéressant vas-y passe à côté ça marche
en fait là je reviens de l'économie
cynique et suicidaire un gros un acteur
massif de l'économie ceni qui est
suicidaire
il vient me chercher pour faire ces
trucs là là bas je veux dire quand on
faisait ça en 2003 2004 il se marrait
là ils font et je sais pourquoi donc du
coup j'en ai fait mon métier en fait je
bosse là dessus vas-y tu peux passer et
du cou du coup du coup c'est ces
ateliers là les ateliers de gymkhana
donc l' approche un peu potager on a
essayé de les mettre en place on a fait
une première tentative donc une première
expérience et ouais c'est une bonne idée
ces ateliers
quand même essayer donc on a essayé une
journée tu peux y aller on a pris un
problème qui était le problème de
circulation pendant les crises
c'était une vieille casserole que je me
trimballe est simple c'était une vieille
casserole que je me mettrai à malley
j'avais fait ça pour la mairie de
montpellier j'avais fait un vieux truc
en flash à l'époque
enfin pas moi c'était pas toi enfin
c'était c'était c'était nous en fait on
avait fait un truc en flash et le truc
traîne toujours en flash c'est toujours
ça qui est utilisé avec quelqu'un qui
est d'astreinte qui par là bas j'ai
désiré le back-office parce qu'il n'y a
que lui qui peut le faire en cdi ou à
cette casserole on pourrait peut-être la
reprendre donc on sait on se dit tiens
on va faire un aide à la décision et des
citoyens en situation de crise
d'intempéries donc on a fait des jeux et
puis encore des jeux voilà des jeux
encore et là tu peux arrêter c'est
encore des jeux des jeux j'en ai plein
ça ce jeu là par exemple pour le décrire
monsieur bois suis là c'est pas mal ici
un petit port ça c'est là d'abord le
bateau là le voilier le superbe voilier
c'est le produit est là il ya un petit
port c'est c'est là qu'on aimerait aller
avec ce produit c'est le cap du produit
de focus on voudrait c'est sûr on
voudrait aller là les angles c'est un
peu les problèmes qu'on va alors ça peut
être les problèmes qu'on va rencontrer
ou les problèmes qu'on a identifié le
vent dans les voiles ça va être d'autres
post-it qu'on va mettre là bas c'est ce
qui va nous aider
et puis sur l'île là on sait pas trop si
ça c'est si on va mettre des trucs on
sait pas trop cédé entre c'est des trucs
est ce que est ce que le fric c'est une
encre ou c'est du vent ont fait on ne
sait pas trop tu peux y aller alors là
heures northern c'est la question qu'il
faut se poser c'est on a fait cette
expérience est ce qu'on a
est ce qu'on a à leur nom est ce qu'on a
réussi
dans ces cas-là vachement bien on va
continuer à progresser sur cet atelier
où est ce qu'on a le en
qu'on a appris et devinez on a appris
leur c'est big échec et tant mieux un
très franc l'échec magnifique belles
chutes heureusement parce que si on
avait chuté pas tout à fait tu vois on
aurait peut-être continuer à faire cet
atelier là on aurait peut-être remis
beaucoup d'énergie mais là on était sûr
de cette bien plantés par mois en tous
les cas premier plantage paroles paroles
hold up de parole l'après midi après un
peu de fatigue il ya deux trois
personnes qui ont monopolisé la parole
ça a été c'était fatigant deuxième truc
le consensus
on s'y retrouvait tous en groupe et on a
voulu faire émerger de l'intelligence
collective et à la place de ça on a fait
émerger une espèce de vague tofu choix
re cercle dire que ton idée à toi c'est
qu'ils étaient vachement original plus
la mienne qui était original on l'a
écrite et on a écarté tout c'est tous
des trucs un peu originaux là et on est
resté sur ce qu'on avait en commun
ensemble consensus mou quoi vraiment et
du coup c'était très flatté qu'on a fait
c'était genre ouais il faut faire une
application pour les gens qui vont aller
chercher leurs enfants à l'école et qui
sont ça va hop
et puis un autre truc s'était morcelé
tous ces jeux là c'était vachement bien
mais après j'avais un truc comme ça tu
vas [ __ ] mais j'ai quoi là c'est c'est
quoi ce produit nom de dieu
je me doutais bien qu'il y avait un
appareil photo cachée derrière mais je
n'étais pas sûr d'avoir toutes les
pièces pas c'était un peu le bordel et
le dernier truc je mettais pas du tout à
temps réel là j'ai appris c'était super
c'est que 1 les personnes qui
connaissaient pas les citoyens qui
connaissait pas trop la proche en fait
son arrivée dans l'île mais tout ça pour
ça le truc et tous pour un pauvre
potager avec un plant de tomate c'est
que les mains on a construit un vp pour
moi c'était mortel s'était exactement ce
qu'il fallait c'était le le produit non
et non mais il était vachement déçu
donc en fait il était urgent de partir à
toulouse
à toulouse crise crise c'est devenu
typhon futé déjà plus marrant le produit
a bougé un peu c'est devenir un truc
comme ça donc tu vois c'est ça il n'y a
pas beaucoup de boulot derrière mais
déjà on avait un premier truc c'était du
graphiste un peu il n'y avait pas de
logique
on avait déjà un premier truc tu peux y
aller encore et on a bossé en fait on a
bossé avec ce truc là mais je passe
dessus c'était un autre jeu quoi on a
utilisé d'odieux plein d'autres jeux là
c'est claude aubry à droite par exemple
on a utilisé geôle à ce jeu là il vient
d'éducation populaire pendant là pendant
l'alerté les réseaux de résistance qui a
émis ces en place en 39 45
on utilise des trucs de un peu de
partout et c'était c'était très bien
voilà d'asie moi j'ai deux minutes
derrière et on a gagné un peu nasillard
on a gagné on a gagné que par exemple
là bas ils ont à toulouse ils ont dit
oui l usine lusine alpes est chez plus
laquelle dans ces cas là on met une
escadrille de drones comme ça de drones
citoyens qui vont rendre compte des
trois super on va faire du réseau mesh
on va faire plein de trucs
du coup on avait utilisé ce truc là
aussi pas trop le temps de vous en
parler
et puis aussi on a chuté un peu c'était
trop de paroles encore tu peux y aller
on a fait une dernière expérience à
bordeaux à bordeaux on a pivoté saisie
voilà qui voter c'est maintenant c'était
le moment qu'il fallait pour changer un
peu les choses
et du coup bon s'associer on a collaboré
avec le d'aubry on est parti dans un
truc qui était un campe une espèce de
fab lab que tu peux voir derrière c'est
un camp douich yourself et là bas on
s'est installé vas-y c'était on est on a
changé le produit on est parti plus tôt
sur les déchets citoyen donc c'était on
avait envie de changer un peu le truc
donc aux lieux de l'assaut à la place de
la circulation c'est quoi les
problématiques de trucs et c'était très
roots un lacet le matin quand il ya
encore de l'ombre mais l'après midi
on a fui sur le parking c'est grave quoi
mais il ya eu plein de gens et on a fait
plein de choses tous ces trucs là des
nouveaux jeux qu'on a testé et vit
encore encore et du coup on a on a
réussi à trouver un petit jet mois mais
bien jette mois genre plaque mois mais
bien et est ce qu'on a appris
eh bien vous ne serez pas parce que j'ai
pas envie de vous le dire vous avez qu à
me poser la question après ce que je
vous propose par contre c'est de venir
explorer avec nous venir faire des
petites exploration venir nous aider
pourquoi pas en faire un à toulouse ou
ailleurs à marseille à marseille a rien
donc on pourrait le faire à marseille
c'est pour rire oh non mais arrêtez
c'est pour rire vas-y tu peux en dernier
et ben voilà je voulais remercier
vraiment les organisateurs je voulais
remercier mes collaborateurs je voulais
vous remercier beaucoup beaucoup et je
voulais remercier tous les citoyens qui
ont participé à ce truc là qui qui
m'aident à délirer et aussi je voulais
remercier des gens mais c'est plus pour
vous je voulais remercier u17 une scop
parisienne vraiment ça vaut le coup ils
bossent niveau collaboratif ils sont
très haut et je voulais remercier outils
réseaux qui font des outils pour les
citoyens aussi et que vous pourrez
regarder ça vaut vraiment le coup et
c'est tout